哈嘍哈嘍各位听众朋友大家好我是小齐。
这里是消费歧视录。
我们上次都有分享过一次关于女性消费的主题。
当时我们是邀请到了年龄快度从20到40的女性。
大家聊的也非常的有意思。
那这一次我们把这个话筒交给了三位男性。
我们想就男性消费再聊一期。
为什么选这个话题。
我觉得有几个小小的观察。
一个是很多人都说男人不够。
尤其在消费这一块。
觉得男性的消费力可能还不如宠物。
它通常是被排在你家庭消费价值链的最底层。
那今天我们邀请的这三位嘉宾。
我认为都不是这个价值链的最底层的男性消费者。
他们对于消费也非常有自己的想法。
那我们先请今天的三位嘉宾来分别。
我们做一个自我介绍吧？
大家好 我是齐成之本的Eric。
我今年36岁
我今天代表的肯定是已婚内中年的一个家庭。
角色来跟大家做分享。
那确实在有小朋友以后。
整个家庭的整个消费的方向。
包括战笔 包括自己的一些消费观念。
确实是发生了很多的变化。
也很高兴今天有机会跟大家做一个简单的分享。
小谢老师 一定要我们说。
保守性消费者还是流行消费者。
我选择不被定义
因为很多东西我觉得是一体两面的。
而且我们在不同的消费场景和不同的消费的标地上。
其实大家的整个想法和判断还是蛮不一样的。
如果要用句话去自我总结的话。
我想我肯定是相比比较理性的消费者。
因为我觉得我还是很少在生活中会被sell。
自己觉得自己还是很清楚我想消费的。
我想购买吃什么？
以及说我想得到一个什么样的一个东西。
大家好 我叫世新。
我跟Edrick其实就差一年。
我是90年的
我们俩虽然年龄相同。
但我们俩的廉政阶段非常不一样。
就是因为我没有婚 没有预养 没有娃。
我觉得大家可能不太关心我们是谁。
大家应该更关心的是。
我们是如何去思考消费这件事情的。
并且说一个消费基金的人每天看消费。
那你们本人怎么去思考消费。
我觉得这个可能是重点。
所以说我的作业介绍可能不太重要。
大家又记得我是世新。
后面我们的讨论内容也许是更重要的。
大家好 我是起身资本的浩悦。
我是99年10月生人。
所以代表了90跨00的一代。
我的消费习惯是横跳在。
像小真青年和欣慰白岭之间的一个消费习惯。
可能是自己会有一些性价比追问的消费。
也有一些自我情绪安慰的一些消费。
所以我的消费习惯大概是这样。
然后可能也反映了一些。
新入职场的年轻人的一些想法。
非常感谢今天大家跟我一起聊这个话题。
就像世新说的其实可能。
各位听众对于消费基金里的消费投资。
如何消费这个话题多少还是有点兴趣的。
然后我们今天选的这几个男性样本。
我觉得也是非常有意思。
大家的消费特点都非常鲜明。
比如说我知道Eric你的家庭消费。
其实你是会为你女儿的兴趣会买单。
而且是会付出自己的经历和时间。
去让女儿有一个比说更快乐的假期 对吧？
对 但其实也说大了。
也没有说为女儿的兴趣买单。
更立即的说就是为了。
因为我女儿5岁嘛？
为了我和我太太
可以在这个时期去分享女儿的快乐而买单。
比如我们今年上半年比较大的一个旅行。
是去新加坡做了迪士尼的游刃嘛？
之前我内部也跟大家分享过。
这个前级条件是因为我女儿本身。
也是一个很大的迪士尼的Fans。
在上海迪士尼也是有年卡。
基本上每个月都会去。
她对于这些人物啊那些故事。
也都非常的熟悉且热爱。
但更多的时候我觉得也是。
我跟我太太愿意
或者说很希望的时候。
在这个年龄段去跟她分享快乐。
有些人会觉得说
小朋友太小了
你带她全世界玩啊？
她肯定也记不住
但对我们来讲不重要。
因为我们能记住
我觉得这个很重要。
以及我觉得这个里面。
很多迪士尼的IP。
包括像世子王这种。
直到今天还是一个相对比较。
普世的一个价值
所以我觉得还是蛮有触动。
对我们自己来讲也是。
其实我想问就是
当你们比如说在游轮这个封闭空间。
你感受到迪士尼和你们年卡运故。
你可能每个月都要去此迪士尼。
这个感受会有很大的区别吗？
我觉得还是蛮不一样的。
显著她肯定会比迪士尼乐园会贵。
就是因为你付了一价。
以及她在一个相对封闭的空间。
她能够感受到更多的互动性。
就像我之前讲过
你在迪士尼乐园可能要拍一个。
和卡通人物IP的一个。
和赵宁的拍对拍一个小时。
你要去看一个演出。
可能你得提前半个小时。
甚至一个小时去APP上去。
预约或者说去提前去排队进场。
但是你在迪士尼乐园上。
其实这些都是脱手可得的。
想知道了YP的服务。
你如果在额外付费。
你可以有更好的更亲密的服务。
比如说我之前分享过的。
公众下午茶几百美金。
但是你说吃的东西真的很简单。
喝的茶就是很普通的Tedology的代炮茶。
有一些下午茶的司康丁这些小的东西。
但是小朋友跟公主是完全凝聚的。
这样去互动可以去拍照。
可以看他们演出
所以这些东西我觉得跟论远。
还是有很大的差异。
我稍微总结一下
因为我感觉其实你刚讲的是一个。
我们三个都还没有家庭。
但是也符合我们能想象的那种。
家庭相废的那种感觉。
就尤其是在有小孩的这个情况下。
你其实是更会为了小孩的。
一个是安全的
然后快乐 体验 付出更多的溢价的。
因为你其实想要的就是一个。
迪士尼故事一样这样的一个。
happy的这样的一个画面。
是 就是无忧无虑的快乐。
如果你在年轻10岁。
你还没有小孩的时候。
有这么个优冷这个价格。
并且你能支付得起。
你就是自己去玩 你会去。
我不会
我在想是不是年轻时候。
就没有小孩的情况下。
你的这个旅行方式跟现在。
其实完全不一样的。
会有差别吗？
我先讲讲我的心态。
我一开始也交代了我的年龄。
我觉得我们那代人起来。
还是有很强的责任感在肩上的。
虽然我们家家庭条件。
其实也还可以
没有承受过太大的。
金钱上的很大的压力。
但是依然会有很大的。
责任感在头上
我举个例子
就为什么我刚刚本职业的回答。
不会跟消费能力都不相关。
跟心态相关
我那时候还在国外上学。
在一个很美的地方。
我会在思考
我是不是过分享乐。
就你的意思是
你在国外上学
你因为自己没有在干什么事情。
要感到焦虑
对
就我把这个场景说出来。
你一定会觉得有点装。
但是是事实是真的发生过的。
你会为这无所事事的。
闲暇感到松开
感到单约 腰和焦虑。
对
我看过一些分析
这个是阿林伙的part。
我觉得就是你会觉得说。
你一定要去做一些打影号的正事。
那个时候的心态是非常不确的。
非常不确
然后张军里面有一段脱口。
就讲了这个
就是亚洲人被教育的时候。
你说的太多人被浪费。
我不能概括
哪怕我玩我得要有点收获。
对
所以这个和经济实力是完全不相关。
因为如果你的心态很好。
像现在的年轻人一样。
95后啊00后一样。
你玩得再便宜
哪怕只是在城市的周边。
交易也去露营
你也可以很秀
而我上学那会我没有这个心态。
但后来有了一个比较大的思想解放。
我觉得也成熟了吧？
现在能比较心安理的。
我觉得现在非常的 chill。
我觉得你刚说这点很有意思。
我们今天在场的另外两位男同事。
大家都是有个Gaif的。
包括我也有个Gaif。
所以今天真的就除了你之外。
我们三个人都有Gaif过。
我们可以分享一下。
大家是一个什么样的心态。
对于Gaif这件事情。
我两段我觉得都算Gaif。
一个Gaif是我工作的。
然后拓产读研读了两年。
别人都读的在职的嘛？
因为在职的话你还有收入。
你还能有学位
但我完全拓产
所以说拓产的我的机会这么很高。
估计这边他是Gaif。
第二个Gaif就是说。
我完全就自己辞职了。
大概一年半的时间。
我两个Gaif的基本上同一个原因。
就是我觉得这个世界上。
有意思的东西太多了。
为什么要把时间都放在工作上面。
有那么多伟大的灵魂。
和那么多伟大的书籍。
然后等着我去阅读。
我来这世上就这么一遭。
就这么一次机会
我是个耗机器很重的人。
随着时间的推移
我就会在工作间隙。
积累很多的问题
它最后会变成一种。
负债营成这种隐形的焦虑。
我就必须盖不干时间。
我就把这个债清一清。
我就要去搞清楚
我耗机的很多问题。
这是我该不该的原因。
所以对于你的两端Gaif。
你觉得是首先不后悔。
然后你觉得是有价值。
后悔什么？
我这人这太爽了
我记得我有一次是。
一整周都没有出门。
再加买了好多
比较健康的那种
面包什么之类的
都饿了就吃面包
喝水
一整周就琢磨一件全新的事情。
就我觉得我进入那个状态了。
心流状态
但是你会焦虑吗？
会为了一个不太确定的未来。
而感到焦虑吗？
有两种焦虑
一种是对不确定的未来焦虑。
这种我不会有
因为我觉得如果使用对于规划好的。
人生就像地球上来的游戏。
你这个游戏都没有。
什么想象空间的话。
我觉得是非常没有意思的一件事。
说这种焦虑我不会有。
但我有另外一种焦虑。
就是我想知道的
我想学的太多了
我觉得我怎么都学不完。
然后这种焦虑之前会有。
但是我后来想通了。
就是那么着急干什么？
本来就对它本来就是。
你在他们的娱乐的一部分。
我就慢慢的去学就行呗。
就是近一寸有近一寸的关系。
所以这个时候你就不焦虑。
所以你其实也经历过一个心态的调整。
对
而且很多时候
你想做一件巨大困难的事情的时候。
你就是会焦虑
然后那个时候你就会先像陈炳。
你先从边边啃起
就是你先从最简单的事情做起。
比如说我之前做自媒体的。
我完全没有学我怎么去剪辑。
怎么去编排
怎么去拍摄
怎么去写完
就是完全从头开始的时候。
这个时候遇到一个巨大的困难。
我就先从买设备开始。
我就去研究什么各种型号的相机。
并且在这个过程中你会发现。
你听到的那些所谓未成功学的那些人。
一般励志的故事都是说。
我遇到了最低谷的时候。
我怎么样除其勇气。
怎么样做很伟大的事情。
然后做了一个Tail-Round。
对吧 起来了
但事实上根本不是这样的。
就是所有人在那个时候你都是迷茫的。
只是那个时候有些人他会把。
在黑暗中把哨子吹得更响一点。
你就是靠着这股焦虑往前走。
不用责备自己
那这样的话这个焦虑就没有了。
浩月你也可以说一下你的经历。
简单做个背景介绍。
就是浩月99年 对吧？
今年27岁
但其实只工作了一年多。
是的
但是比较晚才开始正式进入工作。
所以其实我的Gap是在我的本科。
和研究生之间
但是因为Gap的由头或者脚起。
其实是一个不可预期的因素。
但是我没有主动选择Gap。
但是我Gap下来我发现体验非常的好。
然后接着事情的话说。
我觉得事情其实分为几个类型。
就是一个叫有意
一个叫有意思
我觉得就是可能你把有意当做横肘。
有意思当做竖肘
它不会分为四个象征。
既有意又有意思的事情。
当然是我们最想干。
也最值得去干的
比如说可能有时候是赌书啊旅行。
可能就像这种
有一种是有意但没意思。
比如说上班
可能就是略建于那种。
我目前的工作选择。
就是把它往第一样先干嘛？
然后其实还有一种就是有意思。
但没意义
我觉得这个就是情绪消费的。
一个最毛点的象限。
当然没意义又没意思的事情。
当然就不干
前面三个选择
我会去有一个配比。
然后Gap就是就算第三象征的那个因子。
所以我觉得在Gap之间。
我做了非常多有意思。
但没意义的事情
会让我非常的开心。
比如什么事情
我不会让它好
就我在Gap之间。
其实相对来说
因为刚好碰到了疫情之间。
所以没有办法特别的。
我去旅行什么？
当然我肯定是想去旅行的。
但是我可能选择想替的就是。
比如说我曾经在我的游戏世界里。
然后我每天晚上3点就看世界杯。
因为刚好是2点
就是每天3点都还行政。
然后过在欧洲人的时间。
比如说我就是当时也在游戏。
可能和朋友一起玩不同的游戏。
然后大概是这些虚无的生活。
google了我整个的半年的练习吧？
其实我觉得我们刚刚开场聊了一个。
我们也没有想到
我们会聊Gap这件事情。
因为也是刚刚我们偶然间发现。
大家对于Gap的看法。
其实会有不一样的体验。
然后也有不一样的看法。
我觉得这个世界上有意思。
你通过怎么看待你Gap这件事情。
背后其实也反映着你的人格。
还有你的消费性格。
也是完全不一样的。
比如说我能够感受到的是。
比如说事情
我觉得它是一个
还挺安全性的一个性格。
它在消费上也是这样。
所以我们能够看到。
它买一些我们觉得很离谱。
很贵的一些东西
但它自己好像完全不觉得。
因为它觉得我就是可以just for fun。
或者我只是来体验。
包括耗月也是吧？
我觉得你也相对而言。
还蛮安全性的这种感觉。
我确实是好奇心
哪怕是比如说读的那NBA。
我当时咱们就想
我这两年我到底会遇到什么样有趣的人。
但是老师讲课
他都在讲会些什么东西呢？
我到底还有哪些北大的。
其他的课我可以去听。
我应该是选哲学还是选心理学。
我在这个腐休下来。
这种心态是一直是这样的。
包括买东西也是这样的。
就比如说我们当时咱们投了龙牙嘛？
龙牙它其实是功能性腐蚀。
它的面料什么的都用到这个高科技的。
然后我做龙牙研究的时候。
我会发现原来这个科技型面料里面。
最扭的是十度鸟
比十度鸟更扭的是均用的十度鸟。
它是一个独立的一个国外的品牌。
然后美国他们军队都在传这个东西。
我真好奇
我说那你这么贵一个东西。
然后你最高科技医生的这个衣服。
到底它好在哪
我当时就花了好多一价。
买了一价
讲讲付了多少一价。
2000吧？
2000的一价
光加价是2000对。
加价了2000
我对它外观也不care。
我对它logo也不care。
甚至出来时间之后。
我还想过是不是买点什么东西。
把它的logo遮住。
但是它的那个科技感。
真的会让你觉得特别扭。
因为衣服的面料有一个两难的问题。
你先说一下你的体验。
就是你觉得它这个科技感体现在哪里。
你自己的穿着体验是。
对
第一个它非常非常的轻。
第二呢？
就是我说科技面料有两难的问题。
第一个保暖你就不透气。
透气你不保暖
但是它就是能做到既保暖又透气。
最后的结果就是
它能接受的那个温度玉玉特别广。
就是你穿上那件
你零下15度的时候你不会冷。
你进到室内
然后零上15度的时候。
你也不会感觉到热。
它那个温差能到30度。
这就是它把透气和保暖。
做到即时平衡的一个结构。
我觉得是值的
但是这个值的点
就在于说我探寻到了这个东西的边界。
而不是在于这个东西。
性价比本身如何
它性价比绝对是低的。
但是这个边界你探寻到就满足了。
你首先知道一个东西是10分的时候。
它作为一个标识
你就能评价说什么东西是8分。
什么东西是7分
什么东西是6分
但如果你没有见过10分的东西。
你就没有办法建立一个评价。
去说一个东西
它到底是几分
其实我觉得你刚指的这个例子。
它不一定是一件性价比很低的事情。
我是要想
你这件衣服你可能会穿很多棉。
因为之前我在跟浩月聊的时候。
它会很精确的计算。
这个东西我每天使用它。
我的花费是多少
我觉得这个观念非常有意思。
所以你可以讲一下。
我先接着实行的那个说话。
评价体积对我来说。
可能重要也不重要。
就是当你见过10分的时候。
只有10分才是10分了。
但只当你见过6分的时候。
6分就是10分
所以我的消费观念。
其实就是以最低成本获得最大的愉悦。
可能属于一个自己骗自己的状态。
可能6分我就觉得是10分了。
但是我付出只有1-2分的一个成本。
所以我也能获得10分的快乐。
所以我觉得这个也是计算在ROI之类的。
接着小齐的话说
可能与我上一段工作有关系。
我上一段工作
可能是以做快小品的一个品牌的战略。
我们会去计算单日服用的成本。
沿着这个东西
我会买一些比如说。
能够以天计数
能够以各数计数的时候。
我就会不自觉的去算。
我每天每个大概就算。
比如说面膜会算
习近平我会算
他会在很多的规格上有不同的错配。
所以我的不同品牌。
不同品牌之间是没法可比的。
当我想追求性价比的时候。
我是会计算每天
甚至每个他吃多少钱。
然后可能有30%和50%的。
一个倍数的价格关系。
那我就天人觉得可能他课单高。
但是他的单日服用成本低。
他也是一个更便宜的选择。
所以我会去计算这两个东西。
然后再综合考虑
当我选择性价比的东西的时候。
我会这么去计算
假设你在工作三年之后。
你还会有这样的一个。
计算的一个消费的观念吗？
你还会愿意花
用的宝费的钱额业。
和注意力资源去计算这些东西吗？
会啊 我觉得这个是。
首先我觉得作为一个消费投资来说。
我就计算这个其实也是。
价格带的一个工作的部分。
第二呢 第二呢？
就是我只是对消费的。
因为价格是消费POP开的一个因素。
就是你去研究也好。
计算也好
其实也是对价格一个体系的一个。
benchmark的研究。
或者叫一个system的研究。
就是你知道品牌是怎么定价的。
你知道这个产品值多少钱。
它的成本到底应该去到什么样子。
然后消费者能够接受的。
威力出配大概是多少。
其实这个事情
它可能跟
首先是跟工作相互上乘的。
第二就是
我可能也没有说那么一定的。
经历年百分之一的经历。
就分配到我的购买的消费行为上。
我的消费行为是生活的很大一部分。
所以我愿意分配很多的。
经历到这个方面去。
去做太久了
我觉得做
其实跟阶段是有关系的。
对 我觉得做消费基因的人。
他必须得有人们
他必须得懂生活
他才懂消费者
这是参加做消费投资一个。
有意思的点
这个事情我觉得是两面的。
就是从专业的角度来讲。
当然你得去感受生活。
你得有好奇心
我觉得这些都很对。
然后你得去站在消费者的视角。
去理解这些东西
要不是只看比如说整个产业链。
看供许
看创始人给你画的这个蓝图。
但另外一方面叫做主观的一些偏差。
大家都说可能消费投资。
在很长一段时间
被认为是一个门槛很低的。
所有人都认为这件事情。
我可以去发表一些观点。
背上我自己的一些亲身的经历。
但这件事情其实在商业判断上。
特别因为股权投资是一个很。
复杂的一个工具
所以在这件事情上面。
其实我觉得也是应比得了两面。
才有一点是
我觉得回到我自己的消费观。
我觉得刚刚实行任。
他买军鸟的那个
恰恰在我这儿就会觉得性价比极高。
就我这样等你讲
我这件衣服给我带来的情绪价值。
既是我感受他他科技感。
给我带来的好奇心。
和各种情绪的一个满足。
还是他能给你带来的实用价值。
我觉得这件衣服的性价比太高了。
我口中一下就是
是习近平买军鸟这个体验。
我自己有一个类似的。
就是因为你知道
我不是前两年才开始学滑雪吗？
然后他们都建议说。
你在学滑雪的这个初级阶段。
其实你不要太早的去买你的学习。
因为你得多试很多种不同品牌。
你才知道哪个是最适合你的。
在家雪鞋鞋本身它挺贵的。
就大几千块钱一双。
所以我也是前面滑了挺多次。
大概可能十次之后。
我才会去考虑我要买我的第一双雪鞋。
我要认真地买一双。
但我真的滑了很多钱。
买了一双还蛮高配的一个雪鞋之后。
我非常后悔
我非常后悔什么呢？
为什么没有早点买。
对
真的我很会
但是我可能再早一点。
我也可能很难做出这个角色。
因为我并不知道什么是好的。
我真的抽完那个之后。
我真的感觉啊天哪。
我之前过的都是什么苦日子。
你知道吗？
这种感觉吗？
懂你意思
对
真的会有这种感觉。
它确实是这样的
比如说最近买了台电脑。
苹果新出的Mac Pro。
顶配i5母新的Macs。
然后128这一
然后是买了四万块钱。
四万块钱之后
然后刚买完第二周。
就苹果新的不涨价。
现在涨到五万了
然后我觉得我还这样的意思。
但是可能大家就不太理解。
就是说
为什么你平时工作。
你要干什么？
你要买一个这么高费的电脑。
尤其是在职场当中。
那你电脑就是你的生产密集。
对不对
其实我觉得就AI是来来到来。
不是
我是不是以后
可以在我的电脑里面组一个公司。
然后有很雷震的同时跑。
那这个时候
它就是一个很强行的事情。
并且比如说我现在所有的模型。
都调用的是那个接口API M对吧？
但其实现在很多本地模型。
就是比如说语言识别。
这些模型
其实本地化的模型已经能跑得非常好。
那这样你装在本地的话。
第一你的隐私有保障。
第二就是
你想的时候调用的时候。
你不需要再用API了。
其实现在你用API那个时候也不便宜。
就这个东西
你说有没有价值
我觉得在这方面是有价值。
所以我去买
但也有些我后悔的就是。
我还买了一个耳机就是。
号称是那个无线蓝牙耳机。
各项音质排第一的那个Sansair的HDB630。
它确实音质很好
那它音质对你的提升。
它仅限于某种就是你真正专心的。
在安安机的听音乐的情况下就听。
但是我们大部分就是。
怎么听音乐
现在在通勤的路上去听。
或者你在干什么别的事的时候去听。
那这个时候你的注意力本身就是分三的。
所以说它给你带那个音质的那个东西。
你的注意力都没有意识到它。
所以那你可能
这时候你带着它进个代别。
可能用一个太大的区别。
有但我平时日常还是用API。
因为我觉得它真的很方便。
我通勤的时候还是会选择它。
就它使用的场景就没有那么多。
这个是我觉得当时有点。
性价比可能有点低了一个选择。
对 因为我发现就是尤其是这种。
你日常每天都要使用高频使用的东西。
你其实还是买最趁手的。
就是最好的
对
我们为所谓的美丽废物。
付出过太多地价和采过太多坑了对吧？
但是我后来复盘
我复盘之后我发现这个选择。
它又是必然会发生的。
因为我当时买这个耳机的时候。
是我当时工作最忙的类的时候。
我就是要买一个这个东西。
去证明说我现在这些所有的信物都值得了。
你看我买了一个很贵的耳机。
然后我有了或者享受。
这样的话你才能自相。
它其实是一种心理上的一个安慰。
是一个做心理补偿的执法。
对
明白
所以类似这种消费。
其实我们在买的那一瞬间。
我觉得它的价值已经得到体现了。
哪怕是后悔后悔
对吧 是吧？
就所以对我来说可能。
我也是把消费分成两个部分。
刚才是你讲的可能它是买东西。
是把有实用性和心理价值。
是揉在一个载体上的。
但是我就会把我的消费。
分成两个不同的载体。
他们不能相关联
比如说
这两个是完全可以分开的吗？
对不对
也比较完全
就是它有overlap的地方。
但是我尽量把它分开。
比如说我去买实用性的东西的时候。
我就只会买实用性的东西。
我不会为它付出仪价。
假设我要为它付出仪价。
是为了满足情绪价值。
那我未来有钱肯定看到它。
我用它会后悔
但是比如说
我是把我的情绪价值给分开。
比如说我去买个包。
我去买个华丽的衣服。
我去买个甚至家里的家具败件。
我可以为它付出仪价。
因为我不怎么用它。
我每次当看到它的时候。
我也不会后悔
因为我知道它是为我情绪付费的。
所以它只要美美的在那儿就好。
对
所以其实我为什么在买一些。
实用性的东西的时候。
那么扣心价比
因为我就是这个逻辑。
但是当我去买一些情绪的东西的时候。
我是可能没有那么扣心。
你这个有点意思
能不能简单的说一下。
就是你这个项鲜是怎么划分的。
哪些你归为实用价值品类。
哪些可能是情绪价值。
我觉得高频的更多的就是一个。
像实用的
特别日用
什么洗衣的
比如说护肤的
比如说是小件家具。
这种
他上次跟我说过
那个洗衣宁珠多少钱。
我真是震惊了
洗衣宁珠
你为什么会为洗衣宁珠。
给付出仪价呢？
对吧？
我觉得实实没有必要。
它可能比如说加一些香氛。
它可能有一点点的。
Premium的价值。
但也不会有那么强的东西。
但是比如说我一件。
比如说好看的包
好看的衣服
那它可以
因为它会给我提供情绪价值。
那它也你每天都使用。
但是我穿它的屏次。
肯定会比这种便宜的衣服少。
然后就是比如说
它消耗品
对
而且它不是消耗品。
比如说我买的那种裤子。
就分为两种
我跟小齐分享过
就是我是一个高频。
在抖音上买裤子的一个消费行为。
可能我每个月大概要买两到三条。
所以我的裤子
其实也就是在家里。
有一个专门的衣架给挂上。
可能现在有二三十条都有。
这个比我的还多
第一是男生买裤子。
确实很难买
我需要来试错
然后第二呢？
我是觉得我买的课单价。
大概都在120到170之间。
所以是一个很低课单的。
但是有比如说6 7分的材质。
然后可能89分的剪裁。
我觉得它是有适用配不同的场景的。
但是再怎么算
也没有办法算出3 40票裤子。
要适配的场景
对
它肯定会有overlap。
可能我现在没洗
我就买了一个同样有场景的衣。
所以另外一个裤区是不用清洗。
对
是的
所以这个对我来说。
其实是一个实用性的场景。
然后呢？
但是我也有那种比较高科兰的裤子。
就是线下体验之后再买的。
然后那个它可能就是一个。
跟朋友出去玩
或者是一个功能性更强的。
或者叫对我来说
我能在享受的一个时间段。
比如说户外的时间段。
去穿的一个裤子
那我可能就会付出一个高仪价。
它可能品类是一样的。
但是它们场景不一样。
挺有意思
特别有意思
我觉得你的裤子
每条都很垂一点褶都没有。
很多材质就是
你在洗衣机里洗完之后。
可能就跟
就很皱
我就跟狗嘴里搅过一样。
太好玩了
我跟浩月的向前分。
区分完全不一样
我可能只有一个向前。
我觉得
可能在我这儿
所有消费都是情绪价值。
都有情绪价值
就这一下
我那天跟小姐开玩笑。
一种消费是为了活着。
一种消费是为了快乐。
可能你全都是为了快乐。
我全都是为了快乐。
没错
当然我也
可能有一个客班
因为确实咱俩年纪差得有点大。
可能我也不用直接去买。
比如说特别的
但我同意你的一些底层的逻辑。
比如说一些
刚需行的高频使用的。
特别是想吃的
以及说这些日用的日化产品。
我不需要太多情绪价值。
那我只要支付
我该支付的价格就可以了。
当然在这里面
我仍然会愿意去为一些品牌付费。
为什么品牌
还是会极大地去降低。
我的试措成本
坦白讲
就像刚刚小姐讲的。
我不太愿意去花时间去试措。
去挑了
所以这个是在这些品牌里面。
品牌对我的最大的意义。
所以你现在在书里面。
为你自己花的钱
大家能干比多少
我其实没有算过
但是坦白讲
我跟世芯有一个很大的区别。
我的快乐
我的正反会
我的心流
很羞愧地讲在工作上。
但是你从你的花钱的消费上。
所以我也想说
你给你自己花的钱。
我没有家庭
我没有算过
我只是先从数量的角度来讲。
我觉得我可以给自己花钱的地方。
其实不多
实话说
唯一的心虚然后是养鱼。
对
特别愿意跟我女儿在在一起。
因为我深刻地知道。
我能陪伴她的时间是有限的。
或者是心理上
她可能很快也就不需要我了。
我很珍惜这段时间。
坦白讲
我很愿意
我已经一年多
可能近两年和我太太。
就是没有单独去旅行过。
且也很少和同事 同优去互动。
这个在一切人眼里面。
是一个很大的遗憾和牺牲。
在我这儿完全不是。
我就觉得还挺快乐的。
你明明上次还跟我说。
很需要一次团建的。
很需要团建是另外一个目的是。
因为我想去一些
我带我女儿不太方便去的地方。
因为带小朋友去的旅行的地方。
她有她的特点
吃不了太多的苦
时间不能太长
费得不能太久
开车不能太久
所以是出于这个目的。
而且有机会我当然也。
就是想跟同事一起吃苦。
就我
我
喜欢同事陪我一起吃苦。
我说的
就是我为什么先说我的快乐。
很多缘子一工作
我没用那么多的
像是这样的好奇
心坦坦这样
在课外
我也没有那么把工作当作一个。
所谓的牺牲的过程。
因此我要去消费补偿。
所以我在课外消费的东西。
就很刚续了
所以回答是拼命问题。
衣服
这些服嘛？
所谓的
吃的就不说了
因为是家庭消费的一部分。
下期刚刚讲的我养鱼。
养乌龟
但那个消费真的很minimal。
事情也知道
其实发不了很多钱的。
如果你按金额来讲的话。
一定是家庭消费占主流。
因为比如说
旅行特别是乡上
比较成都的旅行
它一定是从心脑上蹬大的。
帮过一些家庭大剑的一些支出。
就是单身人士
对家庭消费可能有一点点的好奇。
后来就比如说最开始。
你去那个迪士尼玩的时候。
说是为了女儿喜欢。
那比如说女儿喜欢的是其他东西。
然后你去非迪士尼的。
其他地方是不是也是会过的。
同样的快乐
只说迪士尼只是一个。
未必有
那可能迪士尼对你。
或者对于女人是有特殊的意义。
在的什么？
这就是不同的
比如说我们同样说。
追求消费体验或者是一些服务型消费。
但是不同的载体
它的质量蛮不一样。
比如说上海迪士尼。
我觉得目前的槽底已经很多了。
拉开消防处
其实有很多有可能。
拿到了很多不太好的体验。
但是在我看来
还是国内首屈地址。
甚至于是断绑式
领先的一个整体的体验。
它不仅仅是说来自于一些硬实力。
也就是所谓的这家公司。
在过去的近百年历史上。
积累下来的所谓的。
这些intelival asset。
它更多的是来自于。
原来的服务也好
音乐也好
场景也好
硬件也好
这个一体化的一个东西。
所以它会
极大的区分于所有。
迪士尼以外的那些。
以刷项目为主的
它看起来也是一个乐园。
它看起来也给你提供清晰下去。
它甚至也有很强大IP。
但是它的整体性
我觉得
它有个人看
迪士尼还是断绑式的存在。
你的意思是说
就是我去迪士尼
哪怕我今天
就是我一个项目也不忘。
我依然很快乐
都在那里
因为你知道我女儿也很小。
所以很多项目其实做不了。
包括你那天问我
迪士尼尤雷项目是个项目。
有
但是我们根本不care。
所以那些不是重点。
重点是沉浸式体验。
我有点猜想
我的猜想就在于说。
你可能也比较喜欢迪士尼。
其实你带你女儿去迪士尼。
表面上听起来是
是你为你女儿消费。
那其实是你女儿也在陪伴你。
去做一个你
欢老寒童的那种
感觉的一件事情
是这样的
我刚刚开始就说了。
其实本质上
不是为了女儿
是为了这个年龄段。
我们享受
跟女儿在一起快乐的时光。
是为了我们自己
我终于能理解你说这个点。
我觉得它意思是想说。
就是比如说
我自己去的那个迪士尼。
和我跟我女儿去的迪士尼。
它不是你的迪士尼。
是的
对
所以我确实不能说为了女儿。
但是是因为我们
共同萍造的这个场景跟氛围。
蛮好的
你刚说的体验
其实我比较好奇
因为我们通常讲
体验消费的时候
它是一个比较抽象。
比较笼统的概念
我想知道就你而言。
你愿意为之付出一价的体验。
大概是什么样子的。
就你能感受到
我愿意给这个体验。
付一价的时候
是什么时候
我觉得能让我沉浸式的。
感受这一份快乐的。
我补充一点
因为其实
我说实话
我对上海迪士尼无感。
但是我去过东京的迪士尼。
我是有了这个比较之后。
我对上海迪士尼更无感了。
就是因为那边的体验。
真的是很丰富的
我给大家举一个非常小的例子。
你们马上就能体会到是什么？
就是你会感觉
因为日本它整个国家。
它的服务意识都非常强。
去到那个园区里面。
它不只是园区的NPC。
它甚至每一个游客。
他都把自己当成这场。
盛大狂欢的一部分。
我们就走在路上的时候。
哇 每个路过的人。
都在给你say hi。
你知道吗？
就是日本那种很标准的微笑。
游客也给你say hi。
所有人给你say hi。
迪士尼有轮向就是这样。
这迪士尼有一个
他们所谓的tradition。
有一个传统就是
他们会在门板上
贴很多很多
自己DIY的迪士尼的。
IP人物为主的一些装饰。
他们叫
每天晚上
都会有人在看到你的装饰。
然后给你头尾礼物。
然后我们也去分发礼物。
他们叫就叫pixit duster。
就是中国应该叫
魔法礼物
类似这个感觉
就是你说的
因为游客被游客
这间是有机器
强迫动物
这个不能get into the day。
对
但其实就像迪士尼不太能够体验到。
有些地方是的
所以我不用再讲
就是这个完全是个人主观的。
我觉得我到目前为止。
可能我还没有经历到那些。
可能很糟心的事
但不代表以后会怎么样。
特别服务业最大的问题。
其实就是可能规模不经紧。
坦白讲
因为服务的SOP。
其实都不是最重要的。
最重要的是整个团队的经济室。
他们的整个情绪保满度。
以及说能否带动
比如说游客
所以我刚刚你不过标准。
我觉得再往而来
只有一条比较抽象。
就是能否沉浸
对
因为其实我们刚刚聊到非常多。
关于体验消费
关于旅行这部分
就为什么会聊这么多。
我想在这里也小小说明一下。
是因为
其实我在跟大家秦采的过程中。
已经能够感受到
这一部分支出
其实在我们整体的支出里面。
占比已经非常高
然后这一部分消费。
又是能够非常充分体现。
你消费性格的一种消费。
所以我觉得很有意思。
因为比如说日常的话。
我觉得大家可能同样吃的。
喝的
这些其实都大差不差。
你现在已经不是一个。
会对日常的小数的消费。
非常在意的阶段了。
那反而是像这种
非日常的
算大型的
项目类支出
是挺不一样的
其实回到Eric。
就他的这一块消费。
主要围绕着家庭来进行的。
那其实每个人的选择都会不一样。
比如说事情你选择去沙漠。
吃苦
这可能是另外一种精神上的需求。
我想表达的是
你通过这项消费
你能看出来每个人。
他有精神诉求的那部分。
所以想请你们再分享一下。
我想先好奇的问后面一个问题。
就是为什么？
就是你买了很多裤子。
为什么它是裤子
而不是衣服或者鞋。
有两个方面
首先第一是男生的裤子非常难买。
我觉得它的版型和剪裁。
每个人是非常
可能我腿比较粗
所以说可能普世版本对我来说。
没有那么的好穿和。
好看之间的Tradoff。
没有那么平缓
第二个点是
因为我之前生活在广东。
我现在在深圳上班。
那有的深圳上学
广东其实你可以知道。
可能一年是九月穿短袖。
裤子其实可以摆搭。
所以我的消费习惯是。
我可以有99%的。
和大家一样的地方。
但是我要有百分之的不一样。
所以裤子是一个很好的载体。
所以我也会买一些包裹炒碗。
我也会买一些香薰香薰。
也会
然后裤子其实是能够展现在外国里面。
特别不一样
且展现你个人性格的一个穿搭。
包裹的载体
但是T恤和衣服
其实说实话就大差不差。
但是大部分的男生。
其实都是无工精
他都会买很多鞋
我是从上学的时候。
应该是初高中开始吧？
我来现场向你展示一下。
我年轻时候买的鞋。
对 什么A级
也就是档克那时候。
对
我就会买
然后第一是
朝鞋
对 朝鞋
两个原因吧？
第一个原因就是
虽然我们自己不怎么穿校服。
但是穿校服的时候。
鞋是你唯一的差距。
然后第二个就是
其实收藏属性也会比较强烈。
真的有收藏属性
有
就是我很多鞋买的是我没穿过的。
我有问题
那现在的朝鞋是什么呢？
因为前级的那些朝鞋。
其实大家都知道
什么ES什么之类的。
对 现在已经断档了。
其实你可以去看
德务上的朝鞋派行就知道。
之前其实一直是一些什么ES。
一些档克
然后比如说像
Ferfiger之类的。
但是其实现在大家。
在上面买的鞋
主要是也按它鞋为主了。
这个里面就很有意思了。
因为我可能是蛮早就接触。
或者热爱所谓接触潮流文化的。
高中时候上鞋的时候。
在那时候也买了很多鞋。
很长一段时间
其实一代客为主吧？
我觉得它的鞋其实都会被当作盛品。
特别是一些可以不断复刻的。
包括桥蛋的系列
但是大家后来的故事。
应该也都清楚了
一方面是说
有很多的二级的朝鞋。
就逐渐变成一个金融树菌的产品。
就像我们的股市一样。
它一定是有涨有跌的嘛？
其次一个就是
一旦上游这个最大的装家。
也是我们品牌坊
在这个鞋的数量上。
包括在心意上
其实越来越少去做这些思考。
和深度的双鞋的时候。
进市场逐渐的就供它了。
所以我觉得今天其实。
整个球鞋市场
特别是篮球鞋
我觉得就跟前几年不可同仁而云了。
所以之前你们真的是会花。
几千块钱买了一双鞋。
那双鞋这儿我还有个好戏。
就比如说当这双鞋它跌了的时候。
你也不会再想穿它了嘛？
对吗？
不会
不会有这个想法
我觉得有些鞋它是能够。
既日常又收藏的
就是它的颜色配色比较日常和百搭。
有些鞋它就颜色配色。
就比较特例独行
就那种其实就不太会适合日常穿的。
其实我想过这个问题。
然后就是说
我们其实有的买那么多衣服。
买那么多裤子
那么多鞋
我们其实不是为了买那个衣服。
我们是为了买那个符号。
这个是一个很重要的点。
就是在于以前大家没有这个课题。
因为在以前的社会。
大家都有一个很明确的社会身份。
就是比如说
我就是一个父亲
我是一个老师
我是一个什么？
然后你的每一个社会身份都有固定的剧本。
你就应该穿成什么样。
然后你的背面是什么样。
然后你就没有这个。
但当你年轻的时候。
你是多重身份过渡期的时候。
你不知道你是谁的时候。
你这样用消费去彰显的是谁。
消费是情绪的载提嘛？
就是情绪的载提
可以是东西
可以是企业
就是为什么大家现在。
逐步的偏向体验了。
从东西偏向的体验。
对
就我们就很少被游戏充值嘛？
对吧？
但是像浩越这一代。
他就会愿意为了游戏充值。
而且会充很多
我见过一个
直接为一个游戏充了四两块钱。
他有一个专属的客服去。
24小时的满足他的各种需求。
但这个和年龄也不完全相同。
我觉得年龄
你也不会为主播做仿余大哥。
对不对
我不会
但是我们的仿余大哥。
跟咱俩年纪也插伏。
每一个人在不同的阶段。
他的情绪消费的表现形式。
是多棒的
对
非常棒
比如说我吧？
一年大概在游戏充值。
大概是个五六千的水平。
这我会在电脑上玩英雄联网。
我会在手上玩非法足球。
所以我的充值
要么就是去给英雄联网买皮肤。
要么就是在非法里面抽球星卡。
有这两种为主
但是我从25年之后。
就没怎么玩了
所以就没怎么充
但是25年之前
从上大学开始
就是一直有充值的一个习惯在的。
我在玩游戏里面
游戏能给我的情绪是非常高的。
就像我去体验
任何的线下实地活动。
对我来说价值是一样的。
第二
我是觉得游戏是相对较小成本。
去获得更大愉悦的一个方式。
反正我的很多其实铁销。
和也是遵循一个叫低消费。
常识堂
强社交
和高愉悦的一个属性。
就比如说
就比如说我会玩游戏。
或者我有个理念
就是一到六个人
有不同的娱乐方式。
我一个人其实干嘛都行。
就是比如说去逛逛街。
然后看看什么展
这些东西
两个人我就会去打太球。
三个人我觉得没有什么可以玩的。
四个人就叫麻将
五个人就去舞牌上网。
六个人就去玩剧文山。
六个人以上活动
我基本不怎么参加。
我的所有活动
几乎都是遵循我刚才说的那几个DNA的。
还有一个附加属性。
就是可能有一定的竞技的属性在。
我觉得这是强社交的。
一个表演形式
真的我觉得这跟性格还挺不一样的。
像我就是完全只喜欢一个人的游戏。
就是我自己导致我自己感兴趣的东西。
像我有时候要陪我女朋友去打仗的话。
我会把她理解为
我做了一下午思想的旋转路马。
就是她一圈一圈一圈。
她跟你做旋转路马。
没有什么区别
像密室逃脱或具本啥子这种。
像密室逃脱
我就是属于说
我就坐在那里
你们弄吧？
我出去也行
不出去也行
反正我知道最终肯定会出去。
我觉得可能真的是每个人。
获得这个情绪体验的方式是完全没有。
就比如说我顺着时间的话来讲。
我也是
就密室逃脱也好
具本啥也好
对我来说完全不沉浸。
我没有办法沉浸在里面。
所以我没有办法感受到快乐。
我也是
我觉得是一个
stuffer
对 非常stuffer。
真的很stuffer。
比如说我去旅游的时候。
我永远不会选择那种。
只是看看走走的旅游。
我一定要选那种有互动性强的。
要么是爬山
要么是潘岩
要么是苏西
要么是
可能有一些
就是我可以说最近花了。
比较满意的一笔旅游。
就是去一个可能不太出名。
叫遵义的十二倍后。
就是他们有什么飞拉达。
像这种
其实也是一个满刺激的。
大家可能会有
甚至安全的一些疑问的地方。
但我觉得就是旅游。
就要去这种强互动性。
城市体验不到
才能满足自己的欲望。
我太同意
因为我现在老出差。
很多时候你出差
你根本都意识不到你在哪个城市。
因为每个城市都是。
同样的商场
同样的建筑
没有什么特点
所以我现在
以为我反而会去当地的菜市场。
因为当地的菜市场。
会有各种
跟上当地的一些
就土特产的东西
我觉得这个可能会有意思。
对
事先之前去云南旅游的时候。
买了2000块钱的君子回来。
然后
剧桌
然后后来到处
给人送都送不出去的这种。
对
因为我当然觉得云南。
最有的意思是君子。
然后我又是很容易。
下那个决策的人
我刚开始先到昆明。
我就逛入昆明最大的农贸市场。
那里有很多卖君子的。
然后我就没有忍住。
我就下单一批
然后就寄回家了
之后后来我就相隔离达。
还是去哪
我发现
怎么这个店比云南还便宜。
我觉得已经吃亏了。
我就又买了一些
然后完了之后
后来又有次吃饭的时候。
那个饭店在寄那个君子。
然后是一个老国的。
老婆她亲自才能的君子。
我就跟着老婆去搭话了。
我觉得这个才是最优质的君子。
然后我就加了老婆的微信。
然后老婆她来普通话。
她都说不着她
还特别真情地想要求我。
去她们家去看君子。
因为我当时有计划。
我去不了了
我就说你觉得
你有哪些好的君子。
你给我寄点
她说每生的我就给你寄点。
你尝尝你觉得哪个好事。
你在给我付钱
我就没有给她付钱。
结果等了我回到家。
她给我寄了两大箱君子。
为什么这两大箱君子。
就惊到我了
就是两个一立方米的。
两个冰柜那么大
对
我是既震惊又感动。
就是她怎么就相信。
我不会淘单呢？
那我就问她
我说多少钱
她给我说多少钱
我就打一趟了
就导致我家君子就很多。
很多很多
根本吃不掉
到时候开始
就买这种包装
带着还买干燥剂
然后到时候送
把所有朋友都送到那边。
然后后来也没有送完。
我就君子也没有吃了。
你说这还有一个
其实非常有意思的现象。
就是我发现有的时候。
去到一个陌生环境的时候。
你是更容易有一些冲动消费的。
真的就是场景上消费。
这个很重要
就是有些东西
可能你在平时
你也路过过好多遍。
看过很多遍
你不会买
但你只有到那个环境。
到那个情境下
你才会去买
你没有这样子的体验。
对呀？
就是我觉得全都是这种嘛？
就是那个分明道啊？
就比如说
艾瑞克你们家的迪士尼玩偶。
是都在迪士尼买的吗？
还是说我也会在线上买。
多数是在线上买的。
线上
对
我就发现这个点
其实还蛮有意思的。
包括我自己
我个人的消费
我也很愿意去线下。
除了护士
护士是
但是太麻烦了
这很有意思
所以我是一个非常不好的。
线上玩家
我会在一个品牌买。
可能八件十件衣服。
然后可能最后只留下一件。
我经常干这种事
根本便上了这个同事们。
道个歉
恰恰是因为裤子才要线下市吗？
裤子带不下也可以是。
在店里面是很麻烦。
啊 我知道
要拍的就是
我会买比如说
同一个颜色
买三个size
所以我试壁
我买的时候就知道。
我肯定最多只会留下一条。
但如果你在线下市。
你要拿起那么多很麻烦。
同时我又要三个颜色。
比如说
所以我要拿这九条裤子。
而且是不是还有一个问题。
就可能比如说
我在线下买裤子的时候。
我得去很多个店里面。
那我不会
我买
你固定品牌
我几乎是固定品牌。
固定这个品牌
陆陆会加我裤子的。
Wallet Shares。
应该会有可能七十左右。
因为陆陆的裤子还蛮舒服的。
而且也有不同的
他们也破款成领线了。
对
所以很多什么厂都可以穿。
就那ABC
对
是
然后还有很多
我今天这条也是
这个不是ABC
这个是很超薄的那种。
对相同传
也有素系的那种
会有一些可能偏时尚版的。
比如说牛仔裤
比如说Cost那种。
就是偏休闲的
或腿的
或者不同酷型的
所以那个可能占了百分之三四十。
对
差不多是这样
其实我也是
但是我是品牌的
我一般都不去线下。
因为我知道线上
线下没区别
就是我也知道我的size。
我也知道我想要什么颜色。
但是不同品牌的size不一样。
对
就是我知道这个品牌。
其实我有过它的经验。
对
我又不去线下
所以我去线下买的东西。
一般都是那种小众设计师品牌。
就可能有一些比较潮的地方。
设计师品牌我会反过来。
全部在线上买
因为线下很少有店。
所以你们会觉得
逛街买东西是一种麻烦。
很麻烦
我很愿意逛街
我很讨厌逛街买东西。
那你逛的是什么节目。
就是看
比如说各种不同液态。
然后这个商场又多了这个东西。
同一个液态
比如商场也有几家。
然后大家的不同的。
你这就是完全就是。
一种Windows Shopping的这种感觉。
Windows Shopping。
对
我很喜欢Windows Shopping。
但真的带着目的性。
说今天我一定要买到什么东西。
我其实反倒压力很大。
那你们的这种消费。
就是全是目的性消费吗？
不是
我其实比如说买衣服裤子。
我也可能没说今天想买。
但是我就是逛到了。
比如说我是想吃个饭。
然后比如说他刚好在一个商车旁边。
或者刚好在一个买手机的旁边。
那我就会顺路去逛一逛。
然后我没有是想买。
但是比如说我刚好看到一件比较喜欢的。
他又比如说我需要去试试这个池。
然后他在线上可能有电。
可能没电
那我就会去买
但是我不会说
为了今天要买裤子。
我专门去一个店
除非我真的知道那线上没有企业。
只有那个地方有那个店。
我才会这样
是
我的场景很多是
比如在线上看到了。
某一个品牌或者某一个款式。
可买可不买
没有那么高虚
线下如果遇到
就会去线下许消费。
比如说今天看到一件T或者Polo12。
我就买了
但我大概知道我这个品类。
我可能就实践以内。
我多一件完全没关系。
对
所以我觉得都是即时性消费。
但是这个基础是不太一样的。
但我的即时性消费。
就可能更多的发生在网上。
我很少逛街
而且我买的东西的点。
就在于说
我就想买哪个牌子的。
它的最classic的人有款。
因为它肯定是最摆搭。
它不可出错
这种往往都是往上去给你做推荐。
然后就在往下搭
你不来试
然后试着合适就留。
不合适可能就退掉。
但是就这么一种情况。
这么算起来
我的衣服要少很多很多。
这就是可能我特定的。
比如我在学跳舞的时候。
我可能会买几件奥格赛的衣服。
就结束了
是
但是这跟我本人有关系。
就是我本人对于衣服。
细微的差别
我分辨不出来
我没有
你刚刚说了很多
关于念跳的
对
但是
他突然又分辨不出来。
对于设计的
剪裁这些我分辨不出来。
就比如你看
我管心理的都是什么耳机。
然后
参数请
对
都是这种类型的
但这种东西
你说美不美
这个我是能分辨出来的。
但是你说让我自己去设计。
搭配一套
我觉得很难
而且我的主要的保算力不在这。
从这个我也是喜欢谁相反的。
我也是
我也喜欢相反的
所有的算力
参数相关的我都无法。
真正的从我消费者的角度体验到。
我现在说
看到这个数字觉得很牛白。
跟我没有关系
而且我完全伺不住。
所以这个数字对我来说。
完全没有概念
它不是它不一定是数字。
就比如说
所有的品牌
就只要是好点品牌。
它起家都有一个明星大单品。
你就把这明星大单品。
你买回来试就行了嘛？
对于有些
但最后可能会有点负责的。
就是你每个单品
你穿上你都觉得
很喜欢很舒服
大家在习不行
但你不太会搭
所以这个问题
对
我想问一下这个问题。
但是明星大单品
可能有的是你面料参数为核心卖点的。
有的是以它的设计权材为核心卖点的。
所以就那种CVX。
比如这是我的弱项。
所以我搭起来不太能搭。
我觉得花很多时间去搭这个。
为此这个电视就让我很烦。
所以我只要找到一个。
还OK的搭法
我就天天就会穿
就比如说我现在我。
经常穿黑衣服
黑褲子
黑衣服
我觉得这个是不用去搭的东西。
就是它就最简单
OK
对
我觉得可能对我而言。
这个搭配
或者说这个逛街本身是一种乐趣。
我现在就是尽量避免我冲动消费。
有一个小方法是
我有的时候
哪怕在线下室了
我会问他
我说你们线上有电吗？
他如果说有
我一定不会在这儿买。
一个是我要拿走很麻烦。
因为我通常不是目的型逛街。
我只是随便逛到
可能我本来要去吃饭的。
那我现在要另一个东西很麻烦。
对不对
然后还有一个
它竟然线上有的话。
我会我自己想一层。
就是那我以后退货。
我会要简单一点
因为线上退货简单。
万一我不想要了
我的事情有一个好奇。
所以你在线上过户时候。
你是属于会提前加入购物车。
还是说你看到这个。
我就立刻买了
因为你刚刚形容的那个场景。
我感觉好像偏后者一切。
我偏后者一切
我会立刻买
但是只要我放在购物车里的东西。
我把那个90GDG就不会买了。
那我很不一样
我会看到什么有趣的。
都放进购物车
是时候我就会下单。
我购物车里特别腾着的东西。
但是后来发现
就是只要放了购物车。
90GDG都不会买。
我听买的话
我当时就没买
对
不同意
我同意
只要放进购物车一定会失向。
我也会及时下单
但是我放进购物车。
说明我当时没有那么喜欢。
我要考虑一下
我还要不要买
然后放进购物车的。
就说明只有670的喜欢。
我放进购物车的东西。
都是我挺喜欢
但我现在好像不太需要。
或者我想看看
我是不是真的喜欢。
具体的意思
但是如果真的达到80%喜欢。
我会立即下单的
这样吗？
等一下
你的购物车有多少件东西。
我现在现场打开给你看一下。
你们购物车是不是都塞满了。
塞满
我肯定是塞满的
没有塞满
购物车很容易塞满。
你看我购物车只有各位数。
你看我最近
我这个是上周添加的。
Normal的几个东西。
我觉得这个牌子的设计还蛮好的。
就那个户外月也跑得挺难。
我就随便添加三个东西。
Remind myself。
就是OK
这个可以看一看
但我其实不需要
所以我就先放着
我养鱼嘛？
我养鱼刚刚的容量是有限的。
所以我添加了很多。
可以替代的鱼
然后有双鞋也是有点贵。
但我未必需要
所以我就先放着
那天星期一号我就买了。
我618买了一双。
我放了可能一年多的。
一双七老七血
其实我不需要
但是因为它竟然打了五折。
所以我就买了
你会等到它的
我可以需要
如果现在七老七血坏了。
我可能只会再买一双。
我始终会有一双
七老七血的鞋贵
所以那既然它这么那个。
我就买了
你会定去review你的购物车吗？
我会
我感觉我加入购物车之后。
其实相当于
完全不会砍
对 完全不会砍
我连山姆都会
加很多购物车的东西。
然后就可买可不买的。
我就先放着
等我下次去现场
我就看看
哦 上次我是有什么东西是想买的。
看看有没有
有没有句话就买的。
我觉得这种计划性好。
你好厉害啊？
就买例子
其实这里我应该是。
非常幸福的一件事。
我比较有计划
所以我说我觉得
我还挺理性的
应该是一些情绪消费。
我很知道
我买这东西就是为了。
满足我的
刚刚讲的
比如说小众
体现我的品位
体现我的虚众心
举个例子
这些都是情绪嘛？
对不对
我觉得我很清楚
我感觉你是
哪怕情绪消费
我也在脑子里面
有一个笑表
当然这个是我个人的观点。
我觉得大家都在
往更理性的角度在靠。
就是比如说
浩瑜刚刚讲的
我买一些小东西也有情绪。
但我
这个情绪量
我就不愿意付过高一价了。
就是为什么我买个手办。
我就很高兴
我不会为了
这个等级的情绪的快乐。
去花更大的一个价格。
这就是一个性价
有很高的东西
有人来叫做红经纪。
我觉得也是一个
很好的形容词
就是在
大环境可能不太好情况下。
我就就有一些小确讯。
可能带来了情绪
但我有一个问题
就在这个
商品超度丰富的今天。
你们都是怎么去做选择的。
因为我觉得现在选择。
是最难的一点
好看
在选择
就是好看
你得看了很多东西之后。
包括什么衣服
你可以好看
但很多东西你都要做选择。
就是什么软件也好。
硬件也好
然后穿的什么？
起书用品
然后习愿全都要做选择。
选择太多了
我大概知道
你想问的是什么意思。
就比如我拿我举例好了。
因为我之前是一个生活方式编辑。
所以我确实是在我职业。
初期可能前三年
我大量的看了非常非常的懂得写。
所以我现在的选择。
一定是非常
我个人的
所以有些东西我会在意的。
就像艾瑞说的
我会在意好看
比如说你关于服装搭配。
或者一些什么东西上。
有一些东西
我就要节省我的算力了。
就像你说的
我就不做选择了
你知道其实我很喜欢那个淘宝。
他有那个
当你在买一个东西的时候。
他会给你推
就顺手买一件这个东西。
我有很多这种品
都是在那个顺手买的一件。
刚刚刚号越聊的那个螺旋。
就是在一些品类
适用性的讲的品类。
坦白讲
你选了一个相对比较。
合理的价格带
合适的价格带
你基本上已经80%选定了。
它的quality。
对
它的分析
那你们都没有选择困难症。
在一些品类上完全没有。
但是可能非常厉害。
对
就是我为什么说我不追求10分。
因为你永远不装10分在哪。
可能会有更好的
更好
特别是这种
不强功能性和不强参数性的东西。
它没有一个10分的标准。
所以我可能当下呢？
那可能就是10分。
我现在总觉得
有种感觉就是
你要做的选择太多了。
所有的选择都要占用你的算力。
有点累
我后来想到
我特别想分享就是。
我当时上社会学的时候。
社会学老师他说了一段话。
我特别符合我当时心境。
他就说
在这样一个平等自由的社会。
人总是想与众不同。
但矛盾的在于说
你每个人在社会中。
被交付了自由的选择了。
但是大家都生他自己选错了。
你又想穿的与众不同。
又想知道当下的流行趋势是什么？
我们做各种选择
做各种仿佛
充满激情与活力
但是实际上这个选择。
像抛墨一样
随波逐流激烈而不深刻。
因为电视
网络B站有无数的频道供你选择。
但他们都强调流量。
其实你可供选择的东西。
都是一个模子
你在一个创意出来。
就会被无数的人去模仿。
所以这个世界变得广泛而不多样。
所以说
我们追求眼下实际的功力。
但你追求当下的功力。
影响安定外流不安定。
然后因为你担心你选错。
大家就是看起来
我每个人都想不一样。
但你又没有信息
你的所有信息又来自于。
各种主流媒体QOL的推荐。
其实你之后还是被推荐带着走。
我懂你的意思
我觉得你是不是对的。
但有点沉重
我觉得有点绝对
就比如说当我买的时候。
我觉得特别是电商的无线货架。
你或者现在的主流媒介。
其实都是一个无线信息量的输入。
其实你是有挑选的。
压力或者焦虑在的。
但是我觉得从我个人来说。
我是会主观的先定义一个。
自己最想要的东西是什么？
就比如说我挑裤子袖的剪裁。
或者叫锤杆
我挑衣服就是要克重。
我觉得我要定义一个关键指标之后。
就会删选过很多一个漏斗的量。
然后我就能够在一个有。
把它变成一个相对有限的货架。
虽然它还是无限的。
所以我觉得你要定义出自己。
比如说我买超完
可能第一印象就是要好看。
怎么定义好看
你可以需要一个量化指标。
你能在搜索次上去搜。
我觉得这个事情是一个。
很有效的过滤漏斗。
你不能说我今天
推了什么？
我觉得它好
我就买
当然可能有这样的场景在。
但是你有目的性的购买的时候。
你是一定要搜这个漏斗的。
发现词和搜漏斗的一个指标在那。
我是这么理解
诗心当中的分享
我觉得它上表达的点。
你觉得你做出了选择。
你去定义所谓的量化指标。
一定好什么样
然后去定义好看不好看。
使用不使用
合理不合理
把这个漏斗变得越来越小。
你定义这件事情的本身。
这个依据论据
就来自于很多外界信息的。
对你的操控
对
答应好的操控
这个点本身
我觉得不存在太大的问题。
但是
事情我会觉得
现在特别像浩越江的。
年轻人越来越不重要。
就是这世界就是没有意义。
是荒诞的
对
So what
人就是社会性生物。
你的喜欢永远都是从社会性的信息来的。
你从小的同样争议也是你在说的。
好
到最后有几个小问题想问一下大家。
其实我之前也给你们发过。
我觉得我们快问快答一下。
一个是
你回一下你第一次。
心动的奢侈小肥
是什么？
这个奢侈不一定它是绝对金额上的高。
它可能对于当下的你来说是有一点小奢侈的。
但是你非常心动的一个小肥是什么？
第一次买
西桌
刚毕业的时候
你知道那个时候的面试你还得穿成那样。
可能现在已经不需要。
但那时候你会觉得说。
是定座的吗？
修达
那个时候买的平台。
我知道
比较好的平台
对
你会觉得说
我穿上它就是它让我更自信了。
它确实会有这样的效果。
对
我第一次就穿27。
就是那一个7000多段耳机。
小二里面这顶级的。
就是当时侧评里面说最好的就是那个舒尔莱斯尼巴斯。
我专门去回国的时候路过香港。
然后去香港买的
当时港盘还有一个价差。
然后去买的那个耳机。
我觉得确实是比较。
你呢？
我其实应该算是上学的时候存钱买球鞋了。
但其实我租一时吃的那双没有买。
因为被劝租了
不是有多奢侈
四位
大四位
因为当时其实是上学嘛？
而且实在我可能每个月生活费就存下来。
可能就小几百块钱。
可能我就想存个半年什么的。
或者照一年甚至去买这双鞋。
但是我当时就是觉得。
首先我在上学的时候也没有其他的大额消费了。
所以我想有一个这种体验感。
但是你说去买真正的奢侈品肯定又不可能。
所以我就当时那个球鞋对我来说是技效重。
又能满足我去用心和好奇心的一个选择。
所以我当时就买了。
但虽然最后买了可能是个小几千的鞋。
但是是那个时候是我最想买的。
那你们现在回过头来看。
当时让你心动的那个奢侈消费。
你现在肯定是更有能力去消费这个的时候。
你还会为之心动吗？
不会
坦白讲就是因为绿彩的时候我们也聊过。
因为我已经可能比耗月显著更大了。
多少的时间班就是不一样。
其实这些消费已经很少。
让我真的很兴奋了。
就是买也可以不买也可以。
所以说可能就买了。
或者也没有会那种突然心动的感觉。
我很矛盾
我买了那个耳机之后。
我感觉去妹了
我感觉再贵的小耳机你也比不上大耳机。
但是我还是会心动。
所以我最近不才又买了一个大耳机。
我觉得确实是会有月儿的差异。
而且我在家还买了两套音箱。
就因为第一套音箱的时候。
我就买了一个
我觉得中上冷凭是听点不多。
然后我有好朋友知道。
我买音箱之后
他非要塞给我他家显制的一个音箱。
我就会把手机同时连两音箱的两个房间放。
我家突然变成一个KTV歌星。
就那种感觉是完全不一样的。
就还是会有一耳的差异。
就那种氛围就是音乐的律动。
它真的会让你浑身的大脑的波动。
都会随着变化
然后你当时的那个瞬间的改变。
你那个技艺是极其深刻。
所以还是会被打死。
我拿第一个月工资的时候。
我就把上学相买的那双鞋跟拿麦鞋。
你这个有意思
所以是隔了多少年。
也没多久吧？
三四年
因为这个球鞋
虽然是个使用的东西。
但在我这儿定义
它其实就是个收藏属性的。
纯情趣加等的东西。
因为我买了也不会穿。
你只是放在哪里
我只是放在那里
但是我觉得这个东西就是我的一个。
需要被满足的一个梦想型的情绪型的东西。
你现在是买房来租的房。
我租的房
那你租的房有没有七八天。
你就有很多房了吗？
没有 我的鞋都在我家乡的房子里。
我问个问题
所以你的鞋墙会对外展示吗？
或者你会很愿意去拍照。
或者请大家来看我的鞋吗？
不会 我就自己站在心上。
就是你自己的越挤。
对 我自己的越挤。
这点我觉得我跟浩伟特别像。
我们一旦有虚荣心。
我们会满足自己情绪下去。
但他不是修偶
他不一定要发朋友圈。
他不一定要对外对任何人去。
甚至我都没有社交了。
我只要满足自己
觉得自己好像很厉害。
是吧？
按照这个
我觉得消律费还有几个型嘛？
就是一种是效率型。
一种是越挤型
一种是社交型
就是情绪其实更偏下面两种。
但可能你的实用性更偏。
社交和你的效率
可能就是三者选其二吧？
或者三者选其一
其实就能去符合你的购买决策。
我又被你这个故事打动了。
我其实很羡慕
你到现在还依然会为了。
曾经的那个梦想
而心动的这种感觉。
因为我可能真的就。
没了就没了
没有十年
对 我不知道是不是因为。
上年纪还是怎么着。
就是我真的
你们懂就是还蛮被探视到的。
就是这种感觉
因为可能比如说
我年轻的时候
当我比如说
刚开始尝试独自生活。
租了一个房子的时候。
我那个时候非常想要一个。
BOS的那个大影响。
你们懂得很漂亮
放在家里
但我又没有自己的房子。
我只是在梦想那个影响。
就灭都在这边
对
对 我刚刚说错了。
然后它很贵嘛？
但是当我有了自己的房子之后。
太太无所谓了
比如说这个预算
我会放在
我想要买个智能床垫上面。
我就是更想让自己输出一点。
特别有意思
其实消费就是逐渐去灭的过程。
对
好像当你拥有了
或者你有实力拥有了。
那个代表着很多
存在了很多价值的东西。
可能就逐渐的贬值了。
或者不那么有意义了。
所以我刚刚才想说。
我会被昊越为曾经实现自己的梦。
你曾经年少的梦想对你。
上班之后的你来说。
依然值得去实现
我觉得不管再提是一个东西。
还是一个什么样的梦想。
只要你完成了
我觉得这个过程都还是蛮能打动的。
对呀？
因为它对我来说的情绪体验。
也是一个很高的分。
所以我就是假设它是一个实用型的。
我想买的
那我肯定就忘了
但是它就是一个情绪体验型的。
就是我所谓的
可能我的那个有意思但没意义的东西。
我会永远记得那个有意思但没意义的。
特别好
但是你为什么会把它记得在其他。
就这件事我感情的。
我觉得载体其实是不断在切换的。
可能跟当下你说的流行趋势也好。
可能跟当下你的有限的选择也好。
可能它都是一个被动的结果。
很多时候是一个
当然我觉得在你的经济实力。
和你的赋予的经济的足够的情况下。
它的选择会越来越多。
但是你永远回问不了。
当初你只能选择它的时候。
那种稀缺性和它带给你的那种。
被填满的感觉
浩远
所以我特别好奇
就是当你工作买了那双鞋的时候。
球鞋那个市场还在吗？
当时是还有很多炒的。
还是说已经下来了。
已经下来很多
大概几年
我买的时候应该是在25年了。
哦 那已经完全
Folder这个市场。
也不叫Folder嘛？
可能还有一点点的。
但它肯定是没有一价的。
对
但是肯定跌肯定不会跌到。
所以你买的也很便宜是吗？
我记得买成
反正小几千了就已经。
啊？
对
你既然想要这个点。
我真的很大动物
可能它的实际带来的实体。
和这个价格
已经反映了它当时的行情嘛？
但是它给我带来的情侣体验。
它这是我自己独有的。
是
你的情侣体验没有打折。
对吗？
对
OK
但是我刚刚注意到。
一个关键词叫做被填满。
那因为这如果你的收入。
现在翻5倍或10倍的话。
那你这段还能填满。
当时那种感觉
哦 我觉得就是
有句话最重要是
它填满了当时我自己。
所以那个感觉我是不会忘的。
它满足的是
几年前的那个字
不是现在的自己
它用现在的自己的这个能力。
去满足了当年的那个字息。
我们应该都不会有这样的时候了吧？
其实我真的很
希望我自己能有这样。
它现在真的很难
我觉得它很让人羡慕。
我更多的个人体验是说。
等你真的有能力
我会觉得不过如此。
我不想要了
对 我知道
所以有这样的心境。
真的很让人羡慕
对
我觉得现在我想要。
它就是现在的这个样子。
我还没有过那种体验。
而且很多人说
我花钱很多对吧？
就买这个东西
比如说一个七八块钱的。
银钱或者一个什么的。
但你这么算这个账。
它就算错了
你把很多消费
你都没有算到消费面。
比如说你买房子
你买房子带跑250万。
你每个月纯利息支出。
就是大概7000到8000块钱。
也说你如果你不买房的话。
你每个月你都可以买一个。
买一件军鸟
对
但是现在因为你买了房子。
然后你这个钱
消费给金行了
它就是一个问题
我觉得房子在我家绝对是纯小费。
对
而且房子是极大的情绪价值。
其实我跟我大家
因为我们买房和生小孩。
是几乎同步的嘛？
当时我们也聊天
我就到上海
其实你完全不买房。
按照今天的出生率。
也不代表说一定不行。
甚至你可以拿额外的钱出来。
所谓的从下信大笔下证。
你去上私利的学校可能更好。
但是一个房子能够给一个价格。
很特别是我太太带来的安全感。
我觉得是不可逼的。
对我同意
所以我就是把最大的消费给剩。
然后很多大家平时觉得很大的消费。
所以每个人的情绪的点。
我觉得不一样
所以我觉得再次扣了。
所有消费都还是有情绪的熟悉的。
对
尤其是在房地产市场。
现在这个情况下
其实我相信很多人买房就是消费。
很多人买房
我觉得是心里面那份。
中国人路有的
一定要有一个固定的。
安生利民的地方
这么一个执念
很多人买车
一年可能就是那一两次下雨的时候。
能感受到二二中间。
最后还有一个问题是。
一个是你最近正在计划中的。
一个大型消费可能是什么？
还有跟这个问题有一点相似。
是你最近一个想买。
但是还没有买的东西是什么？
不一定是实际的东西。
也有可能是
我最近想去一个什么地方。
但我还没去
也可以是一个体验。
在计划当中就是十一份旅行了。
因为今年十一正好。
和中秋也连正
所以会有一个超级大强价。
如果你愿意再前两天价的话。
一定会去比较远的地方。
所以会是一个很大的消费。
但是还没买
只是在想
对 原因是
我之前跟小姐分享过。
可能想去美国玩
但是我发现
昨天马上我跟大家在讨论。
第一个现实的障碍是。
没有时间办签证了。
现在签证好像已经办到10月份了。
不知道为什么会那么火。
然后我们俩的10年前。
碰巧又多过期了
所以就很麻烦
第二个是说
确实带小朋友出去。
因为这次要飞很久了。
如果买机票的话
是飞可能就
经济上就大概1万多了。
如果碰好的更贵
确实会有一些纠结。
我没有最近计划想买过。
因为我想买东西
我已经买了
我如果买东西不计划。
我想调了两个最大的情绪。
价值的支出之后
我觉得有很多
大家看起来很大
但其实不大的小贼。
所以我都已经买掉了。
其实好像也没有什么特别想买的。
首先我的消费永远。
你现在已经没有那双鞋了吗？
就当年的那双鞋
其实没有特别说
我购不到
然后说要存很多时间。
和经济去买的东西了。
很少
我的消费就很少有大额的。
消费品的支出
可能在消费体验上有旅游相关的。
我觉得这11规划。
可能也实现在一个。
比较在考虑的事情吧？
大概就是这个
然后在消费品上
我几乎都是高品低格单的。
飞钢去产售
然后也是可能几十件表强。
所以就没有一个计划性的。
想买的大额的东西。
我能纠正一个你最开除的问题。
就是我买的最奢侈的。
跟消费市场的没有问题吗？
我后来想
我其实买的最贵的消费。
其实是我读过那个两年的NBA。
对
那两年就是你第一。
你学费是二十万
但是你的机会成本是一百多万。
然后你再加上你的生活费什么的。
然后你还有社交什么的。
可能又有四五十万。
你可能再给小两百万出去了。
就加上机会成本
第二我们当时还有。
一学期可以去全世界。
任何一个学校交换。
只要不是像卡佛资产和那种。
很名额 很有限的那种。
你既然想去任何一个国家都行。
我当然选的是伦敦政经。
去交换的一个学期。
就是你再能又能学习。
又能玩 又能体验。
真正一个学期
第三我们还有一个项目。
是那个访学项目
然后你可以去全世界。
我们有五个大州
每个大州都有一个学校。
你可以去访学两周。
访学系也是上课再加玩。
我们当时是去了
以色列的西伯莱大学。
那次以色列之前
我们是在耶稣撒冷。
就那两周的经历
我觉得也是非常有意思的。
再加上你又认识了一群特别特别。
听见一起上课的一些朋友。
而且 NBA 班。
真的大家多元性太多。
你看到了太多
平行世界的生活
对你的整个见识又有很大的影响。
就这笔我觉得两百万声。
其实它是改变了我的人生归期。
因为我原来是在一个养企。
我原来是做
刚开始做核电
后来绝非洲挖又晃 对吧？
等了这个输之后
我后来又去了
Di 公司去做红资。
然后现在又来到消费基金。
就是整个有一个重大的拐点。
其实就是那次求学。
那个求学真的改变了我。
挺多的
那两年就是一个你极大的。
丰富你自己的这么一个过程。
觉得很值
我觉得很值
而且我们觉得很
这个才是最贵的
确实是
好
我们今天的录制差不多。
就到这里就结束了。
大家如果有什么觉得有意思的点。
以及自己消费中有意思的经历。
可以给我们分享
拜拜